that are you know uncertain
you know myself included uh
that's what's sad about it most so how
do you go on from here i mean you can
just hit on some of the realities and
benefits how do you go on from here
how do you take the next step
yeah bro that's a good question i don't
know i really don't uh
there's a lot of unknowns going into
this offseason now
and
they just i'm gonna have to take some
time away for sure and
clear my head and just kind of see
what's going on with everything
but it's uh it's pretty tough right now
oh hello wednesday edition of pft live
on
sunday aaron rodgers giveth on tuesday
he tries to take it away we're gonna be
talking about that
over the course of the next 10 15 20
25 minutes who knows we go as long as we
want in the opening segment of the show
we can't go too long because coming up
in the second hour of the program the
brand new head coach
of the new york jets and the winner of
business suit season the only guy who
looked comfortable and at ease and
commanding in his
style full suit at his introductory
press conference robert sullivan the new
york jets head coach is going to join us
good morning chris simpson going to be a
great day great are you ready i'm ready
let's do it
you're conflicted today you're going to
be conflicted today no i'm not i'm not
worried about anything what are you
conflicted
with i'm not conflicted about anything
well you've been conflicted for almost
four years you can conflict yourself
right out of here if that's the issue
but uh um uh well i i thought you may be
conflicted because
of what we're about to play so we'll see
maybe you will be maybe i can convince
you to be conflicted about
what transpired because as we say hello
to our
audience on peacock siriusxm 211
sky sports nfl prime time 7 p.m
uk and ireland time and also nbcsn at 9
eastern and podcast whenever wherever
however as we say hello to you
we remind you that we've been talking a
lot about aaron rodgers and the
the thing that he clearly and plainly
said the things he clearly and plainly
said
at his end of season press conference
after the packers lost to the buccaneers
so
he was on sirius xm mad dog radio with
the pat mcafee show
yesterday and he tried
to put as chris would say the toothpaste
back
in the bottle here he is talking about
his future two days after he talked
about his future
i don't feel like i said anything that i
hadn't said before
um you know i said it the first time i
talked to the media
uh just it was more real the realization
i think
uh that my
ultimately my future is is not
necessarily in in
my control and i think that was what
just kind of hit me in the moment i was
thinking about
you know aaron jones and corey linsley
and
other guys we have under contract uh big
dog
you know guys who i don't know what
their future is going to be and then
myself included uh now obviously after
the season that i had and
um you know potentially winning mvp
and you know we obviously made it to
another good run
i don't think that there's any reason
why i wouldn't be back but
look i think there's there's not many
absolutes that you guys know in this
business
so to to make an absolute statement
about something
that is is not an absolute just i
i didn't do it you know and i guess
that's why i went kind of
kind of nuts there's times where you let
your mind go
to maybe i'm going to be a packer for
life or i'm going to be
you know i'm going to be like a tim
duncan or a jeter or kobe and play with
one team i attacked a rear
i think naturally you dream about that i
mean that's kind of like a dream
scenario and i've talked about that
for much of my career i think you know
when when they drafted jordan it was
more just like the
reality kicking in going hey that's
actually never the case there are no
absolutes in this business
and i think it's a beautiful thing to
sit with and to
and to wrap your head around and i did
and and i got to a beautiful place about
it
doesn't mean that that's not still a
reality i think that's the only reality
is that there is no absolutes in this
business
there's a lot there that aaron rodgers
said chris and
let me just start here i'm going to
start smoking a cigar on the air oh kind
of like that
i kind of like that improve that would
help your brand
too let me tell you we were having this
conversation on the pft
check text chain the other day um one of
the reasons why
we don't have like the booming announcer
voice
like a pat summer on a john faceni is
because we don't have anybody smoking
five packs a day anymore that's very
tough to help you get to that voice here
right
there but but i digress um
okay look
aaron rodgers said what he said nothing
he said
yesterday changes what he said he's
explaining it
he's giving it some context i don't
necessarily
buy all of it i think at the core is
what we have been unpacking for the past
two days the idea
that the presence of jordan love changed
everything because last year
when they lost to the 49ers in the nfc
championship game chris
aaron rodgers didn't speak in absolutes
he implied
absolutes like hey we're going to get
one of these soon well
you're saying you're going to be back
you're not saying you may not be back
you're all in
you're hey we're going to get one of
these very soon
right we the packers are going to get
we're like you're back you're all in but
now that they
drafted jordan love right that rattled
him
and and i think that's one of the things
that really came through in what he said
yesterday he got rattled by that and
that punctured his bubble that made him
previously think i'm going to get to
stay here as long as i want
and while i'm here they're not going to
go get my replacement
they're going to use those draft picks
to help me win as many as i can
and that fantasy that best case scenario
just disappeared in that moment and i
think that's the difference between last
year
end of season press conference after
losing in the nfc championship game
and this year and i don't know was it
planned was it deliberate did he have it
written down on note cards i don't know
but he's clearly been
carrying it around ever since he heard
the commissioner say
that the packers traded up to draft
jordan love well yeah
and so i get that i understand where
he's coming from there
and it's a legitimate question for him
to have sure
and i'll shut up and let you talk for a
little bit before i say anything more
well i like to keep going and going and
going well
i mean just listen on that first part
right there i mean yeah
listen the thing i always love about
aaron rodgers is he's honest
i i don't know you know of course
there's no absolutes in football you
know and then
of course he's okay to question what's
going on right now
because of just everything you just said
yeah he thought for sure
i mean geez i i should end my career as
a green bay packer whoa that's not gonna
happen so he's being honest about that
and then i think the other thing that's
just different from last year mike
is the other thing he brought up at the
start of that interview there with
mcafee and
and um aj hawk it's just he
there's there's some big contracts up
this year for the green bay packers so
there's a chance that the team
and the core of the team is not exactly
the same next year either and i think
that's what he's referring to with all
of this as well
and i'll stop there for now to answer
that part of the question where do you
want to go with this next well no but
i think you're you're right he senses
that changes
are coming right and in theory
he could be part of it and
i i just look no one
from green bay is going to say we don't
want aaron rodgers next year
and aaron rodgers isn't saying i don't
want to be there
next year this is about in my opinion
and this is where i struggle charles
robinson was on brother from another
yesterday and he made a great point and
i've dealt with this for the past 10
years because any time
aaron rodgers sends a message that is an
intriguing message
that is a message to the team coaching
staff
front office whoever someone who's part
of the organizational structure above
the locker room
anytime he does that there's no reward
to be gained
as someone in the media who hears what
he's saying
understands what he's saying and points
out what he's saying
because he doesn't want us to mention
the message he doesn't want us to notice
the message or
talk about the message he wants to make
these little passive aggressive
digs that he hopes the people they're
intended for
will catch them and that no one else
will say anything about them
and he gets a little pissy sorry london
when people like me or like i i
assume he's upset with multiple members
of the packers
reporting corps who were tweeting and
that's what got my attention nothing
rogers said got my attention what
what what got my attention was people
like jason wilty saying he sounds like
somebody saying goodbye i was like holy
crap i got to stop what i'm doing
there's another game on now i got to go
listen to this damn press conference
so that that's that's that's where it's
a little wrong in my opinion
like here's a guy that he i don't always
agree with the the statement that it's
passive aggression like i think he's
just honest
he just talks but he sends
and then okay but people take these
messages and they go where they want
with them
oh he sounds like he's sad and it might
be over
i never said he said well i know you're
saying about the tweet it sounds like it
could be the end whatever okay yeah
he's freaking uh killed right now that
he lost the nfc championship so yes he
is sad
and then he was honest about the state
of the football team and where
things are and then you know do you
really think he was honest do you think
he was being honest when he said
on certain futures myself included yes
wait wait time out time out do you think
that was an honest reflection by him
that he may not be on the team in 2021
because that's what he
that's what the words meant i think
that's just being honest
okay we don't know what it meant we just
don't know nothing is for sure that's
all he was saying
he doesn't know if corey linsley is
going to be back if aaron jones is going
to be back
he wouldn't he wouldn't have thought
that there was no way you'd draft a
quarterback last year while i'm in the
super bowl window
so now he's learned anything can
freaking happen
therefore there are no absolutes so so
do you think he believes he's not going
to be on the team i don't know
i think right now he knows he's the best
player on that football team
but he's probably also yes he believes
he's going to be on the football team he
said that
but he's he's also sitting there going
all right where the hell are we going
from here and where is this going all
together
and i think he's just he's a guy that i
think flushes this
out in front of us sometimes right i
don't always think it's a
messaging but but well let's keep
talking but yeah but
look again you can't drop the turd in
the punch bone act like it's i i hear
you
right well and he didn't avoid it he did
go out there and do an interview and
addressed it once again and tried to
explain himself to a degree it's not
like he says these things and then goes
hide in a corner and goes
you guys figure it out you'll know you
know so i do i do respect that
he just and he did it in a way yeah that
puts the packers fans minds at ease
and avoids him ever being perceived by
them as the bad guy i think he wants to
desperately avoid what happened to brett
favre when it falls apart between him
and the packers right
and so and that's why the messages come
through in a subtle way in a way that he
has plausible deniability later to say
well i was just being honest or i was
just
look here here's the core of it let me
boil it all down because what he said
yesterday reinforces my belief as to
what the situation is
he wants clarity as to where he stands
with the packers sure and that comes in
the form of a contract
that makes it obvious based on the terms
of the contract
that he's not just the quarterback for
2021 he's the quarterback for 2022
and possibly for 2023 that the next
three years are locked in that i don't
have to worry about being on a year to
year arrangement
and i don't have to worry about going
out there and having an mvp caliber
season
every year to avoid the conversation
whether or not they're going to flip to
jordan love
that's what he wants by way that's what
i believe now again
he may not like it that someone other
than mark murphy
or brian guticun stermat lafleur got
that message and is actually talking
about it publicly
but that's the message i think he's
sending to the packers
i want to know where i stand and if you
give me a contract
that binds me to the packers for the
next three years i know where i stand
and if you don't well i know where i
stand right i just want to know where i
stand
i think that's his fundamental message i
i don't think
that's i don't think that's off base i
don't and i think that's
you know again i think anybody in a
workplace
football whatever it is whatever your
job is they would like
to know some of those things i know you
don't always know that
but but yet you know it's clarity for
him
one like you talked about a hundred
percent where do i stand
am i going to get to call my own shots
are you guys going to push me out of the
door when
all of a sudden i still think our team
is good or you know that so he doesn't
know
right and the other part of the reason
you want clarity at least in my opinion
right now if you're aaron rodgers is
okay i'm the quarterback are
are we gonna go all in or are we gonna
you know
dip our toe in the water for a year and
like maybe get just an okay free agent
and then the next year we're going to
think about hey jordan loves careers
coming up here soon let's start
formulating
what we're going to do around him he's
got to worry about that clarity too
about the direction of the team
and how it affects him and i think
that's part of the conversation as well
yeah i don't think he's interested in
being part of a semi rebuild right
right in the next year or two and the
salary cap dropping to the range it's
believed of 180 million
for 2021 could be a factor will be a
factor and actually
could help the packers get some bargain
basement veterans to come in
if they are willing to be aggressive and
go against their nature although we saw
what brian gooda koontz did a couple of
years ago with all the veterans
that the packers brought in so different
than what we'd seen in the prior 15
years
there's going to be that opportunity
this year because you can say we got
aaron rodgers
the other teams don't come sign on with
us
we're close to the top of the mountain
you're not going to get paid a whole lot
of money by anyone this year
make what you can here play into
february and then you make your money
next year hey
that i mean look they should have a sign
outside the stadium that says that
i mean and it should have been there 10
years ago
so that that's one of the problems of
the organization all together but i
you're exactly right it could fall in
the right place to where
yeah they get some players up there for
some bargain deals and
they they change it around he i'm sure
like us
any sports fan him he'd like to see them
make a little more investment in the
team as
as it pertains to supporting around him
i'm sure
you know the one thing i'll say too like
you know we sit here we look at all the
you know the underwhelming draft picks
and things like that i don't want to say
underwhelming because these guys
have done very well i mean they've
helped their football team out they're
just not
difference makers to where you know
teams are
changing their schemes or their matchups
because they're going oh no
you know saint brown is split out here
we gotta check to a different coverage
or alan lazard
no they're good players they're
certainly worthy of being in that
rotation and getting the football
but they need another marquee guy but
wait last thing i wanted to say mike i
bet you the one thing
that probably out of all the things
rogers doesn't like that's out there
right if i'm him
and i'm trying to put myself in his
shoes and you know i'm pretty obsessed
with him and i
i follow the words he says he probably
doesn't like the contract talk thing
that is probably one thing he does not
love to hear
because that doesn't paint him in in a
in a good light in any way
so that that's one thing that i don't
know how much he addressed that
yesterday i know he saw one comment he
did
yeah but we let's talk i'm glad you
mentioned that let's talk about it or
let's listen about it because here's
aaron rodgers from yesterday with pat
mcafee and aj hawk
talking about the reports originating
i'm not sure where that he wants a new
contract
i did see you know some of these
comments being made
and i don't want to go through them one
by one and talk about you know the
falsehoods being said out there but
i haven't even had the conversations yet
there's conversation to be had i'm gonna
have them
um with the right people but it's the
same conversation we have every single
year you know there's nothing
you know there's no like big you know
i'm gonna come to the table with you
know i need this and this and this like
look we have honest conversations about
about uh where we're at every single
year and
uh whether that's with brian matt
mark i've had these conversations for
years i think it's part of like being a
leader
uh on the squad and and having a pulse
of the team
and the direction that we're going and
we'll have the same conversation we do
every year
dude's brilliant he's brilliant because
look what he did he pivoted away
from what he wants to what he's actually
communicated to the pack because we
haven't had the conversation yet well no
one said you had the conversations
no one said that as soon as the game
ended you stormed into brian gudekun's
office
and said i want to have a conversation
right now about my contract that wasn't
what anyone said this is something that
percolates over time
throughout the season and comes to a
head when the season ends and is an
indication of where the ball is moving
we're not saying the ball's already
there
the ball is moving in the direction of
him wanting a new contract he wants a
new contract to get the clarity
see it's too hard for him to be the one
to say
sure it's not about the money and that's
that and this speaks to
your point he doesn't want to be painted
that way right you know i made the point
i can't remember who responded this way
it may have just been an email i got
from somebody who was listening to the
show
saying oh he needs financial security
and the point is it's not financial
security
we're talking about security and clarity
as to his objective
employment yeah right and and i think
for him it's too hard to go into that
minefield
because the harder you try to explain
yourself the more likely it is you're
going to step on a mind right
so he so that's i think that's why he
just wants
none of that to be mentioned discussed
even though that is the core vehicle for
him
getting the clarity that he wants
you get a contract that because that's
how teams
speak they speak through their actions
and when they give you a contract
that ties you to them for three more
seasons
you have your answer jordan love
is closer to jimmy garoppolo right than
he is to aaron rodgers when aaron
rodgers was the guy who was waiting to
take over for brett favre see he's
lived it as jordan love no doubt so the
question is
is this guy me or is he the jimmy
garoppolo who's going to get traded in
the fourth year of his contract to
another team
right no i mean you're right he lived it
he witnessed it he got to see
what happened with brett favre how that
was dealt i'm sure you know he's talked
about brett and probably some of those
private conversations
that went on between him and the packers
back in the day and it scarred him he's
not going to forget
who wouldn't you know you of course
you're going to remember something like
that
i think the money thing though yes
that's where
i would imagine him um being a little
protective of that conversation because
i i do understand that listen i read the
comments under your article yesterday
about this and then
you know some of the comments and what
people say are just so off base and
ridiculous
that i want to make an account and
become a commenter on there and just
start going hey i'm chris sims
and that's a dumb comment and let me
tell you why tune into the show tomorrow
at seven at peacock okay
all right so first don't read the
comments just don't just don't read them
it's not worth it i had to tell my wife
that 10 years ago well i just like jesus
i can't believe what they're saying it's
like don't read them i know
i just like to get a vibe every now and
then for the feel of like what people
think about these things the money thing
with rogers
it's not like he if if there is
conversations or there was conversations
or anything like that
i don't think it's like he's ran in the
door to green bay he's like i want more
money
i want you to pay me more money correct
right that's correct yes
i agree no i i know i'm just setting it
up it i'm just explaining it to the
other people i think it's more like what
you're saying
it's just i don't give a damn about the
money i just want
something that shows me you're committed
and that's probably probably why
he's trying to exactly like you said
answer that question very smartly
and divert down another road so it
doesn't get into
i look like a brat because i'm asking
for more money because i don't think
that's what it is at all
a new contract provides commitment
and a commitment provides clarity yeah
and what he wants is clarity and the
fact that he said
myself included means he
currently doesn't have the clarity he
would like because a year ago he had the
clarity there was no hesitation there
was no equivocation
when he was upbeat after they got their
asses kicked by the 49ers i remember
watching that press conference thinking
why is he so upbeat
he's upbeat because hey we're going to
get one of these coming up here in the
next few years
and then in came jordan love instead of
a receiver taken with that first round
pick or
some other piece that could help them
with the fourth round pick that was
packaged with the first round pick to
move
up to get jordan love right that's the
thing that was
the cold splash of water in his face and
that
accounts for the difference from last
year to this year and that's why he said
what he said so
and and this is what's just so
frustrating about it because
he doesn't want us saying those things
he just wants the message to be
sent and received by the people for whom
it's intended
and the rest of us in the middle to just
go
about our day and that's not why we're
here we'll put the graphic back up
i don't want to say that i think it's
about just you know it doesn't want the
conversation to where
you bring something like this up it's a
huge pro football your pro football talk
is the most popular sports nfl website
that people go to
okay and he just well no but yes i mean
he doesn't want to read that garbage
crap but he but he also understands how
that headline and even the things that
you wrote can
funnel into another conversation and all
of a sudden be perceived totally out of
whack
and i'm sure he's aware of that as well
that's why you go on
pat mcafee show for 45 minutes and try
to put the toothpaste back in the bottle
but look at this graphic look
he won't say it you i and you understand
why you won't say it
but my god right are you kidding me are
you kidding
are you kidding me 33.5 million the same
as jared goff
are you kidding me 500 000 a year more
than kirk cousins are you
kidding me look at the names that he has
clustered around and look at where
the top of the market has moved and yeah
and look at the lot like it's more money
yeah yeah he does
it's okay for us to say it yeah it's not
okay for him to say it
but i think that as much as he would
like to stuff me in a locker and leave
me there
until i'm just a skeleton uh i think he
should be paid more money
yeah i mean i i under yes he should be
uh there's no doubt but like you said i
don't think it is about you know the
dollars themselves it is about
the the commitment and that's what it's
all it's going to be the continued
conversation here um but that
quarterback list is you know
it's comical in a lot of ways i just
think when you look at it there you just
go look at the bottom of that list
well it just it shows everything we've
talked about
that you don't need to pay some of these
guys three and four times more money
than the others
the second best player on your football
team it's just gotten out of whack that
way that's crazy
you know those numbers and names should
be like the elite
yeah watson wilson mahomes you know josh
allen lamar jackson coming up in the
future it's for those guys
you know everybody else it just
shouldn't be that way in my opinion
well and that's why i think we're going
to see yeah and should see a tiered
system we talked about this recently
this idea that just because you're the
next quarterback to come up for a
contract
so you know it's the old thing where
you're putting your hand on the bat
height right higher
no that's not how it works you get you
get to put your hand higher
a level lower you get a smaller bat for
for jared goff and kirk cousins and
carson wentz right and the truly elite
quarterbacks get the bigger bat
and they keep moving up that one that's
how it should work
and you've got aaron rodgers caught at
the top of the small bat
when he should be at the top of the big
bat it's that simple yeah
it's that simple and yeah look hey it's
been tough for a lot of people over the
course of the last year folks don't want
to hear us talking about
the difference between 45 million and 39
million and 33 million a year it's all
obscene to a lot of these folks but the
reality is
these are the guys who bring value to
the sport they are the ones that we're
tuning in to watch that's right and it's
about respect
for aaron rodgers and what he's
accomplished and it's about that clarity
he's looking for because without that
new contract
he's on a year to your arrangement he's
in a situation where the packers hold
all the cards and for 2021
yeah we definitely want him back but you
know what if he stinks in 2021
yeah where's it go then then we got
jordan love right and
we're not talking about 2022 we're just
talking about 20
21. in on on that regard mark murphy the
packers ceo was on
the fifth quarter show on wnfl in green
bay
monday night and and he addressed the
issue from the packers perspective this
isn't going to surprise anyone but it is
mark murphy's voice
on this topic so let's hear what murphy
had to say
i'll say this there's no way in heck
that aaron is not going to be on the
packers i mean he's
he is he's gonna be the mvp of the
league
might have had his best year ever he's
our unquestioned leader
and you know we're not idiots
we're non-idiots i love that we're not
idiots i just want a t-shirt that says
we're not idiots uh but but here's
the the one little caveat
if he seeks the clarity that would come
from the commitment that would come from
the new contract
and they say no that's
when the first domino falls and the
question is how many more
fall behind it because if you don't give
him the clarity if you tell him
no aaron you know here's how it works
we've paid you a lot of money over the
years and
you signed this contract and it's got
three years left on it and
you see here's the way this this
operates we get to decide when we want
to rip it up
you don't and you kind of know that
going in you're a smart guy
uh so we reserve the right to rip it up
after 2021 or 2022
if we feel like we're ready to move on
to jordan love and that's just the way
it is
yeah we know you'd like to have a
commitment that makes it impossible for
us to do that well we're just not going
to give that to you if that's the
message that is sent back to him
right either that bluntly or more subtly
then that's when that's that's when
myself
included becomes relevant oh well yeah
that's that's when the you know the
store high in transit hits the fan okay
i don't know
what to say because i that they better
be careful
playing that game with this guy i mean
to me you know first off
he's different than brett favre you know
i do think he's a little more
indoctrinated into the team with
relationships and things like that brett
favre got done with the year
and went back to mississippi and said
hey i'll see you guys next football
season that's it
and i know aaron rodgers not there all
the time either but still
you know i do feel that there's a little
difference there
and i just don't think i think listen
at baseline i think aaron rodgers knows
how to play
the political game a little bit more too
if this thing got ugly
and you talk about the passive
aggressive uh comments or
just how smart he is in general he he
can make life very interesting in green
bay if they don't give him the answers
they
that they should give him this thought
has occurred to me several times this
week and i'm just going to go ahead and
say it brett favre
is a dog and aaron rodgers is a cat
that's the difference
right you're right there is i can see
what you mean there yes you're right
and that's fitting because i'm kind of a
cat person so i like that i like that a
lot but you like to be
you like an animal that manipulates you
and well i don't know it plays on your
feelings
or i manipulate it too so i don't know
it goes both ways i think
either way but hey mark murphy green bay
guten coast everything up there there's
a lot of respect and like
and they're not idiots i know that i
know
but it was a semi-idiotic offseason and
it'll be a semi-idiotic offseason once
again
if we don't do something to go all in
with aaron rodgers that really in the in
the in the big scope of things
they played the worst freaking team and
lost to the worst team they could have
played in the nfc championship game for
the sake of the organization
because the lack of support the jordan
love thing
tampa went all in with tom brady he's
got weapons galore
and they had dropped out tristan works
right tackle
first rounder oh that's why we didn't
hear zadaria smith song
in the name all game they got there in
part because the guy that wasn't on the
the on the field that day antoine
winfield who we've talked about a lot
he was a huge contributor to the game
the receiver from minnesota that you
talked about all last week
johnson he has a big third down catch in
the game over the middle
oh rookies helping bam players helping
tom brady all of those things i just
think that was
it's it that i think even infused the
conversation more about all what we're
talking about
well think about the contrast in tampa
bay their number one objective
even more so than winning the super bowl
exactly is making sure tom brady comes
back next
year right we want you back next year
please come back please come back don't
retire don't
don't ask to be traded or released we
want you back
and uh aaron rodgers has to look around
and wonder what is the plan
are we are we all in are we trying to do
this
and again the question is this folks
what kind of quarterback is jordan love
is he jimmy garoppolo who is there just
to
apply the red hot poker to aaron rodgers
in the later years of his career
and motivate him and drive him and hope
that that carries the packers to
championships like it did
for the patriots and tom brady or is
jordan love aaron rodgers the guy who at
some point
is going to take over for aaron rodgers
and we saw how they hatched the plan in
2008 when they went to brett favre
in february and said we need to know
right now what you're going to do this
season the perfect time to get him to
say well if i have to tell you right now
i'll retire
and then they barricade the door they
hope he doesn't come back they give the
ball to aaron rodgers he does come back
they deal with it
aaron lived all that front row seat
right in the middle of it smack dab in
the middle he went in front row see he
was on the stage for how that all played
out and
and it was awkward and he and i think
he's trying to avoid
being put in that same kind of a spot
yeah and to be fair
rogers hasn't you know left the
organization
uh dangling in three previous offseasons
either we can't forget that that was a
huge part of why that went down and why
they treat no
rogers has not done anything wrong to
the organization or threaten them with
retirement or anything like that
so there is a difference there too
you're right he's
cons consistently said he wants to play
into his rights and he never wants to
play for any team other
right in the packers period so he has
behaved in his mid-30s
the exact opposite of the way that brett
favre did right and i think that's what
stings him even more
it's like look guys now that i'm getting
up in years
i'm not going to screw around like brett
did and and
try to hold you guys hostage every year
and make you think am i coming back
and then you do this to me okay well
well
oh it's going to be a different ball
game now that you've done this whole
thing with jordan love and
and here's the thing we support i
support i think they are doing him wrong
i think he does need to be upset and i
think he does need to seek the clarity
that will come
from the commitment that comes from a
new contract chris yeah i think i i
support that 100
i know you do no matter what he thinks
of me no matter what he says no matter
how many times he says people shouldn't
read that crap maybe they should
maybe maybe somebody out there who's
making decisions for the packers should
because
we think that he's right and we think
that he that that they they have done
him wrong right as
it relates to jordan love and the help
around him yeah no no doubt
we agree hi
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports